[Music]
how's everyone doing today very well
before I first of all Congrats on the
movie it's fantastic but before we get
started talking about it the only reason
Collider gets to be at the Toronto Film
Festival is because of our sponsors I
want to give you a huge thank you to
Nordstrom Canada for allowing us to
cover movies like Ford Ferrari jumping
right on in this's one of the things
that's I think so fantastic about this
movie is it's the kind of movie that is
really tough to get made nowadays people
are you know there's a lot of escapist
fare but this is a really smart adult
movie that doesn't dumb down anything
for the audience great characters talk a
little bit about for all of you guys
reading the script for the first time
and realizing what kind of special
material this is definitely felt for me
that this was in the best sense of the
word
in the best sense of the word an
old-school movie and I think rarely do
movies like this get made nowadays and I
think the only time they do is when
they're in their hands of a real genius
from the best of the best and there's
very few of them out there they get to
really do what they want and that's I
can definitely say that about about Jim
I think only he gets to make this movie
only he knows how to make this movie and
I think he knew exactly what he was
doing every step of the way and he he's
one of the best no I think that's the
thing when I when I first got the script
and you read it and it's it's one of
those scripts that you're like okay well
this is something different this feels
elevated you know jazz and John Henry
but they did such a great job and it was
it was one of those things we were like
I can't wait to see how they're gonna
put this on screen and you know saying
that with Jim you knew that he had
exactly every scene was already shot in
his head he knew exactly what he wanted
and it was such a joy to feel like
you're in such safe hands on sad you
know it just every day was very cool it
was really good
script the script was really good and
I don't think the story was really good
and compelling and it's kind of all on
the page at the same time it's the kind
of movie the milieu of the film it's
just something that movies do better
than any other medium fast cars they
just don't work as well on TV or in the
theater you don't see a lot of fast cars
in a theater so it's very cinematic and
so James was obviously the guy to make
this movie I don't know how the hell he
did it is to read it you're like I don't
know how the hell anybody does this how
you marshal all these forces to make a
film like this it takes somebody like
James to do it
I you know I it was one of those scripts
where you read it and then you like you
just go into this world and you forget
about time and and you like you finish
it and you're like oh wow that that
where did time go I was like two hours
or three hours I just read this script
and it you know I just had to keep
reading keep reading keeping it's just a
beautiful you know and also the way they
described the cars and the races and all
of that is something that I've never
seen before in the script you know how
how real and raw it was and how you know
you could picture in your mind and then
obviously I met Jim and he's incredible
he's such a you know descriptive and
he's such a he's he knows exactly what
he wants and when you get in the room he
tells it he tells you what he wants in a
sentence and you get it and you and and
you know what to do and he's really
supportive and and I had a great time
with in the audition just talking to him
about the scenes just playing around and
I was really you know really excited to
work with him and I think those these
two things together those two at the the
dream team of a movie and so you know I
I was very excited to start I think in
the time where movies have become
primarily you know escapist particularly
when you go to see a movie in a theater
these days it's often times to go see
escapist cinema that's primarily made by
computers you know and the thing is when
you read this script I I didn't assume
that they were gonna do it all practical
but they did they made all these sets
the you know so here there's that
opening sequence in the Ford factory and
to walk into a set where they've been
calling cars for years of 1963 Fairlanes
for two years they've been gathering
pieces and whole cars to make this movie
to build that set and then to be there
and see the way that they were doing
that with the Ferrari factory and the
Lamont racetrack and all these different
things that there was this was practical
filmmaking I always described it as the
Lawrence of Arabia car racing movies
because that's what it is what one of
the things I also think one of the
reasons the film works so well is that
you have time in the film to invest in
the characters it's like an hour and a
half the first hour and a half is
essentially a lot of character stuff and
none of the characters are like they're
all three-dimensional you and there's
not these crazy exposition dumps it's
just really great writing as actors talk
a little bit about preparing for these
roles and I guess just talking about the
characters and preparing I don't that
question really wasn't good I'm gonna
well change that no no no means that
post right exactly oh it's a fine
question right and we we all did a
variety of things to get ready will you
do what you need to do to get ready I I
didn't know anything about cars and I
still don't but you know read the book
of the history of this thing tracked
down an old Henry Ford biography watched
some YouTube clips watch the LeMond 66
documentary you do what you need to do
to figure out where where where you are
and then yeah to be on the set like Josh
was saying it to have those cars in
front of you to see those to see those
cars working its transporting it really
puts you in the in the time in the place
that that the movie is made I mean I'm
very glad that I was playing a character
who was you know in or if these cars
because I don't think I could have
hidden my excitement if I was like
playing someone who knew about cars and
was like
over it because they were just it was so
incredible like watching the races and
and and as you know how did they're all
they're all of the cars and they're to
hear them all and to to see them all and
it was just amazing in one place and and
you know I just I didn't really have to
act to be honest because it was it was
all there and and you know they're
pretty beautiful to be honest the cars
actually there I'd never noticed that
before you know they're really stunning
so that was cool you know that was guest
preparation for it seeing those and yeah
yeah so much of this experience I
imagine for all of us has to do with the
fact that it's you know headed by two
extraordinary actors you know Christian
Bale is utterly brilliant actor and to
see him play this character where he has
moments alone in a race car where you
deeply care about what he's going
through that's a very hard thing to do
but also the movie has a real Butch
Cassidy Sundance feel to it where
there's this extraordinary friendship
between those two guys and also between
everybody this movie I think boils and
the ideas of friendship and I love and
and in combative friendships and come
this amazing scene between her her Molly
and her husband where their their love
for each other is overwhelmed by the
things that they're going through and
then they have to battle through that I
mean just to me that's where the movie
really excels and why it's so thrilling
to watch is because you care about the
people so much actually when it's switch
the question so we're at the Toronto
Film Festival some of you have not seen
the film yet can you actually watch
yourself on screen or will you introduce
the movie and then just walk right out
of the theater I mean I haven't I
haven't seen it yet so excited and I
like watching it I mean it's it's
definitely a part of the it's a part of
the experience is seeing the finishing
product for me and and seeing you know
all the hard work that went into that
and I don't like to watch it twice I
think once is is enough and and then I'm
then probably the next times I won't see
it again but by yeah I'm very I'm very
excited to see it
I'm gonna watch I mean I yeah it's
watching myself is not my my favorite
thing in the world but but this one I'm
really really excited and eager to see
what what everybody did how Jim put it
all together and and I I can't wait to
see you know the thing that I feel like
is most difficult is how - for the race
sequences to be delivered in sort of a
cogent way where you really understand
where we are in the race and I feel like
the aim here was to kind of go after
that also with the relationships and
where everybody is with the
relationships and and how the two of
those things get getting married and I
know that that's what he was trying to
do and I know that he did it and I can't
wait to see how that works cuz I have no
idea how that's possible you're gonna
walk out very happy tomorrow right yeah
I mean it's that thing of I'm luckily
there's so much of the film where I'm so
excited to see what everybody else did
and see the actual mastery of the
filmmaking that's a lot the desire to
see that's a lot bigger than you know
the horror of seeing yourself but um
there will be moments of that but it's
it's more about you know we had the most
incredible crews well I mean that's the
one thing there was such a great vibe on
set and is to see the culmination of
everybody's work I think that's a really
exciting thing so I'll stay yeah I'm
gonna watch for all of you guys I'm
fascinated by the process of actors and
what you do to get ready on set do you
have for all of you guys do you have any
sort of like pre shooting rituals things
that you do before every take and has
that sort of changed through your career
I mean I tried to bully Noah before
every take just to sort of get that
goods
just to get that good familial tone
going one of my favorite moments of
making a movie happened actually in
Toronto and with Christian Bale where I
was driving to do a scene in American
Psycho with Willem Dafoe and the card
picked up the van had picked up Willem
Dafoe and myself from this little hotel
that we're staying in down the road here
and I got in and I was just like god is
Willem Dafoe I'm about to go do the
scene in this movie and Christian Bale
and all of it and I was 19 years old or
whatever it was and I was so nervous
that I couldn't it was a borderline
shaking and I I just leaned forward I
was like mr. Defarge Scott tie I'm so
nervous right now and he goes Jesus so
am i and I remember that moment being
like striking to me and he turned he
said if you're not nervous something's
wrong and so to me it's always on a
daily basis that thing of if that
feeling is there that sort of excitement
and uncomfortableness and and even kind
of a terror that goes into it now you
lose that in the process of making a
movie over a long period of time but
that that feeling in the beginning that
you either nurture or you work with to
compel yourself forward I guess as part
of it that you're taking a bit of a risk
in a way I think for me it's it's
different each time I think that's
what's really exciting and I'm really
grateful for about what we do and about
about the journey it's like the the stew
of of all the people coming together and
and all the elements coming together
each time for me puts me in a completely
sort of different mindset and a
completely different process and I love
that I love that it's different I love I
really try to push myself to be open to
what what's what's kind of around me and
and this was one for sure with where I
knew everyone around me was incredibly
wonderful and anywhere you look there's
somebody that you believe there's
something that you trusted you believe
that the furniture you believe the scene
you believe the cars and you surely
believe that the people around you the
other actors and and
there's just a lot of truth and and and
definitely believe believe in the
director so yeah it was this was a
special one I don't have a lot of
rituals ritual way to prepare it was a
great ensemble spirit there was a great
ensemble spear on the set people
encouraging each other and and and and
Jim leading the way I I don't know
there's so something about the way he he
marshals all of that it's inspirational
and and with all of the cars and the
exhaust and the heat and the and the
extras and the I mean the there was a
massive production so to try to get your
focus down to just where it needed to be
you really had to rely on the other
actors the other people around you and
that's what builds that ensemble spirit
which was it was really thick on this
film I know all of you guys are probably
always getting in every take but once in
a while I'm sure you mess up can you
share for each of you is there a day
that you are still embarrassed by from
myth messing up a take and why by
messing up takes you would just have to
quit I think that's also part of the
process you see or if you can share a
story from because no III like hearing
about the deep you know the the fun on
set I have a scene in the this film with
Matt where Jim decided that he wanted
the scene to sort of take place over the
course of these steps and I'm telling
you I fancy myself a pretty athletic
dude but these were the most awkward
steps you've ever seen and I had to say
this line shuffling and I knew I was
either gonna definitely fall but I I
just I mean it was literally just
basically falling forward and shuffling
down in the in the most Awkward way so I
felt like that was pretty ridiculous and
every time I just Matt would just be
laughing at me just saying you look so
ridiculous on those steps you know yeah
so yeah
when Christian had to carry me into the
house and you know I'm not I'm not a
small person and it was just hilarious
to watch him like have to hold me up and
like carry me it was like a quite a long
walk up to the house and use his arms is
like aching afterwards and he was like
torturing him you know he's also very
thin in the movie it's not like he's
carrying a bunch of extra weight one of
the things I think we we sort of forget
he had just come off ice where he had
gained a bunch of weight and I think he
had a very very short time to lose it
all and we were sitting one of the first
days we had a read-through and Noah and
Christian and myself were sitting in a
room talking about just different stuff
with the script and no and I had just
ordered lunch and we're sitting there
chowing down and it wasn't until it
wasn't we were almost finished that we
realized a Christian sitting there
drinking a black coffee looking really
really hungry and not very pleased with
either of us who were just shoving
chicken into our faces but yeah I don't
recall making any mistakes except the
same day of you're sure your stair
shuffle I had a you know one of those
phone call life moments happening where
I was stupidly had my cell phone with me
and I answered my phone and blah blah
blah
life happened so I walked back on a set
and it was an early on in the shoot for
us and I just totally messed up my lines
I mean terribly so that Matt turned to
me I said are you with us man and I was
like yeah I literally had to say no I
didn't in my head I was like no I'm not
but I probably should not have my cell
phone on set for the rest of this movie
because when Matt Damon says are you
with us man and you know you're not that
yeah I realized I needed to be um that's
fantastic
my last thing for you guys it's another
acting question sorry for indulging the
a lot of times I've spoken to people and
they enjoy shooting the rehearsal and
other times they love doing you
three four five takes in they feel like
they're they're comfortable for each of
you is zero do you feel like you you're
usually on unlike that first take or
takes you a little while to sort of warm
up I mean I mean honestly it's really
different with every dog job you do it's
different people different director
different sets even and you know
sometimes obviously I feel like a lot on
this because they were quite there was
some quite big sets there was some kinda
like broad sets it was good to rehearse
and it was good like because I was you
know obviously a lot of cars and they
would sometimes explosions or stuff that
happened and and so you know we had to
get it right we only had a certain
amount of time time to do it so I think
on this one I think rehearsing is is was
was necessary before we for you Adolphe
delved into the the scene but you know
it's different it's different on every
job you do really I want actually
everyone to answer if you don't mind
well I think and John and I can speak
about this quite a bit because one of
the things with the way Jim works is Jim
knows exactly what he needs
so he will ask for even just a fraction
of the scene and he'll ask for that
fraction just to be done sometimes just
repeatedly and so it some directors you
work with where they'll want you know
the whole scene fluidly done multiple
times or in Jim's case he's so precise
in terms of what he needs that he will
just ask for that and then oftentimes I
say okay do something different in just
that piece and that piece he might not
exactly he knows what he's searching for
but he's not necessarily he'll give you
and he's directing fully I'm not just
every actor he's directing every aspect
of the movie meaning the lighting the
cinematography all of it this is my one
of my favorite moments of this movie is
that Jim was very frustrated with the
extras during the scene the opening
scene of the movie where Henry Ford
comes out and gives the speech and he
said there's this extra deep in the
background that's doing something very
awkward with his hands and he came out
and he's yelled at all the extras that
he said listen all these actors
everyone's here doing their job if
you're not doing your job I'm in a CGI
you out right and so he made everything
but then he comes back in and we're all
sitting there watching do you remember
this and jim-jim turns and faden's like
why are you paying so much attention to
that extra and he turns he says I am a
doctor I don't look at the face I look
at the pancreas and that moment I was
like it's Jim doesn't look at the face
he looks at the pancreas and I was like
that's totally what he's like as a
director but Lillian the complicated
elements of the inside of the body even
the details there so my knew that nobody
else is looking at which is what makes
him so masterful but that's why the
movies so good do you guys want to share
anything I just think III think really
the same I think you know you just like
what Josh said he's well he's shooting
it he's editing it and and and it's not
about I think sometimes you're sort of
required to go in and and vamp and
perform and and it's all about what we
feel but I felt on this one you know -
for lack of a better word you you're
kind of like a cog and and your
performance is being tied into a car
going around a track at 120 miles an
hour that you've got to hit at the exact
right time and you trust implicitly in
your leader and and and he wants it to
be a very very certain way and you
absolutely trust in his way and you got
a you got to kind of do that so it's
it's less about what you're sort of
feeling on the inside and whether you're
killing it or not it's more about am I
am i fulfilling that his his vision
because you believe in it that much sure
I think also the funny thing with Jam is
you know he would talk so much about
this movie for him was about
relationships because he was like I
don't even like cars that much you know
but he he had such enthusiasm for the
story and the heart of the film and not
I think was his primary goal every day
that every scene moves you or makes you
feel something you know so it wasn't
even though he's a master with all the
technicality of it and that was
incredible to watch you know he's this
conductor of this incredible symphony
but he just kept the focus of the heart
of the film sort of front and center all
the time
what what everybody else you're a little
long-winded sir well I you asked about
if we prefer rehearsals or more takes or
fewer takes and I I just don't know I
just have to trust the director on that
it's not I don't think I ever turned to
Jim and said I need another take on that
I assume that Jim would ask for it if I
needed it trying to be felt he had it
then he had it and we were done and
moving on and so it's really Jim
question more than its Ohio State
question but listen I'm basically out of
time even though I have 75 other
questions I really mean it sincerely
it's one of the best films I've seen
this year you guys are gonna love it for
the people that haven't seen it thank
you so much for coming in today and
talking and I wish you guys nothing but
the best thank you